hello thank you for joining me for this
episode of gaming review my name is
caleb Envy and today I'm gonna be taking
a look at a game between nama signifi
and Alexandre Castel yolk from the 2028
Karan's Cup this was a game played very
well by Alexandre actually and we're
gonna see some endgame technique in this
one a lot to look forward to here so
let's just jump into it so we've got the
game started d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight
c3 and we see Bishop b4 a nimzo-indian
for you guys and there are many many
ways to play against the nimzo-indian
example III Queen c2 simply Knight f3
even f3 even Bishop g5 even g3 these are
all available options so of course Nana
does none of those and plays Bishop d2
everybody's favorite move and this idea
is kind of similar to some Queen c2
ideas you simply want to recapture this
Knight not with the pawn but instead
with the bishop this is the idea of why
it's opening so instead of taking of
course black just castles we now see
Knight f3 black continues with b6
getting developed we see III c5
challenging White's Center and now after
a3 the bishop does take and the bishop
does recapture and once again now that
this night is out of the way White's
control over the light squares is a
little bit weakened so black takes this
opportunity to bring the knight to nice
central square on e4 white continues
with Roxy 1 we now see Bishop e7 using
the long diagonal and after Bishop b2
black doesn't really want to play d5
blocking in the zone Bishop or her own
Bishop in this case so instead she plays
d6 controlling some dark squares and
allowing this Bishop to breathe white
now castles and we see Knight takes c3
from white from black rather this move
of course just aiming to eliminate the
bishop pair before it becomes a problem
and this is probably why this Bishop d2
line isn't really all that common from
the white player well I can simply play
like this eliminate the problem of the
bishop pair and then black should be
doing just fine
white recaptures with the rook we now
see Queen e7 getting this Queen off of
this soon-to-be open D file and
supporting some more of these pawns
white now expands further on the Queen
side with the move B for black finishes
development with Knight d7 we now see
Knight d2 we're trying to bring this
Knight over to some Queen side squares
we see a 5 from black aiming at this B 4
square challenging White's expansion on
the Queen side and perhaps daring her
even to play this move b5 when with the
the closing of the Queen side black
would be much more free to play on the
center and also play on the Kings side
even depending on how ambitious she's
feeling that day so of course instead of
b5 white plays a better move Bishop f3
which is actually a pawn sacrifice and
we do see black go for go for the pawn
here with a takes before a takes b4 C
takes b4 note that this rooks under
under pressure so you don't really have
time to take on b7 although this would
be playable for for white going in
Fernan and going in for an endgame like
this instead though we simply see rook
b3 and now perhaps best for black was to
eliminate these bishops before shutting
off this diagonal but she did it in the
other order simply playing d5 keeping
the bishops on the board now we see C
takes d5 and actually after Bishop takes
d5 the bishops come off anyways but
instead of having this pawn on e6 this
this pawn comes out to d5 now in this
position white plays rook b2 black gets
a little bit more active with rook a3
and now we see Queen e2 and f5 from
black and smoothes a little bit of a
mistake it's a little bit over pressing
it is the term I would like to use it's
creating a lot of weaknesses
specifically on this diagonal and on
this seventh rank all in an effort to
play f4 and take on e3 and here it's
it's simply a little bit too slow for
example after the move Queen b5 which is
played in the game already
there's too many threats in the center
for you to keep this rook on this nice
active outpost
you have to come back to a five now this
Queen kind of worms its way into blacks
position black does achieve f4 but it
doesn't really come with the devastating
effect that one could hope for why it
simply takes this pun off the board and
after rook takes f4 the fact is your
King has really been severely weakened
by the absence of this F pawn white
continues with Knight be three black
player okay three giving up this pawn on
d5 in return after Queen f7 Queen d6
note that this Knight is kind of hanging
but if you take it
this Knight on g7 falls as well as well
as actually the stroke enough for got a
really careful of these things so
instead we simply see rook-a for
friend--other friend
we see rook f6 trying to evict this
Queen from its active post on d6 the
Queen comes into c7 but now Knight f8
and black has undone most of the damage
that she did to her position here with
the pawn on f7 she had good chances to
kind of even press for more with the F
pawn gone she's using her pieces to kind
of cover these holes in her position
which is just fine so white takes this
opportunity to finally trade the Queen's
realizing that the black King has found
safety so we see King takes f7 after
Queen f7 and now after Knight d2 this
trick comes to d6 trying to pick up this
D pawn Knight f3 and ninety-six adds
even more pressure rook d1 is actually
White's mistake here because tactically
this does not even defend the deep on
much better is rook c1 eyeing some
squares on the C file trying to gain
activity in exchange for this deep on
and said after rook d1 well I can simply
capture this it that it's as simple as
that there's nothing left to calculate
you can't take this because after rook
takes there is problem on there is a
problem on your back rank here that
cannot be dealt with so after Knight
takes d4 there's also no funny business
with rook d2 we're gonna get hit with
Knight takes f3 check
and this would also be a horribly losing
endgame
so after 94 now white simply plays King
f1 but now Knight b5 and Black has come
from comfortably regain this deep on and
is up upon in this end game we see rook
D to be one trying to take this guy but
after Knight c3 rook b4 rook b4 rook b4
let me see look d1 check 91 black
defends this pawn with B 5 and this is
just slightly uncomfortable for the
white player here this B pond is pretty
far advanced actually on the fifth rank
and it's starting to create some some
annoying threats of becoming a queen in
the future and in the meantime this
night is really stuck here on the e1
square perhaps best for white was to try
to get out of this by playing f3 and
King f2 but rather than that she
actually chose g3 this move doesn't
immediately solve her problems it allows
black to bring her King sorry I messed
up a bit first rook b3 Rick c1 then she
plays this move g3 but this does allow
the black King to get back into the game
just a bit with King e6 and after king
g2 this was White's idea but the problem
is the trade of the Knights is actually
beneficial for black here in this rook
endgame black is very much going to be
pressing despite it being quote-unquote
three pawns versus three pawns in a rook
endgame the fact that this be pone is
past and already so far advanced with
this King so far into the action means
that a Casteneda has very good chances
to win this game she starts with King d6
bringing the King closer to the pawn
this rook comes to c8 trying to get
behind the passed pawn a reasonable idea
and after rookie seven black is doing a
nice job of controlling her seventh
ranked rook b8 king c5 and this pawn is
actually going to go all the way to
victory here f4 is on the board but now
b4 King f3 this King simply walks the
pawn up the board rook c8 rook d8 and
eventually rook c8 king bee too but now
f5 be three white is simply far too slow
the kingside to deal with this past pawn
and now a very very nice move here from
white actually or from black actually is
the move rook a7 this move of course
granting this King Asylum on the a file
from any checks so the king can safely
get out of the way of the pawn and allow
it to promote g5 on the board simply
king a to King e4 and now b2 and b1 is
making a queen white sacrifices her rook
for the pawn hoping to use her own king
to force black to sacrifice her rook in
exchange but it's simply far too slow f6
is played and actually g6 is black's
choice all moves are really winning here
you can take you can play g6 or you can
ignore it everything is fine for black
but we do see g6 and after king e5 rook
a five check and blacks point is that
she's picking up this G pawn and while
white is successful in forcing let's see
forcing blacks to give up the give up
the rook here with King g7 unfortunately
the King and pawn endgame is just dead
lost after g5 the game did get played
out to its full conclusion here but it
turns out as gnana I'm sure calculated
accurately white is just a few Tempe too
slow and after Queen g5 Alexander Nana
I'm sorry Nana actually did resign here
of course Alexander calculating it out
very well of course if the King steps to
h8 it's the only legal move and black is
going to pick up this pot so very nicely
played game by Alexander Christina ik
showing some technique in that rook end
game despite material being even once
again we see the power of the outside
passed pawn being able to promote with
the help of the King and Alexandra
managed to take down her opponent in
this game thank you so much for joining
me on this episode of game review my
name is Caleb Denby and I will see you
next time